à une tenue il a loué ou faire on dirait
les vieux film savages henri desbals des
acteurs j'ai l'impression qu'il ya des
loubards c'est un truc dont vous rêvez
d'être tous bords dont je dis ah non
mais là c'est vrai un peu de boxe
oui ça fait un peu tout le temps tout le
monde je cale perçoit la fouetter tout à
l'heure aux loges vip vous défoulez vous
savez moi j'ai voté pour surfer pour une
crème la bonne avertissements
immédiatement
c'est l'avertissement était le manque de
concentration et dépendant manière
chronique
enfin on peut arrêter avec cette photo
ça rigolait arrêter ce n'est pas ça
n'est pas moi
on n'a mis aucun n'a été arrêté que
cette photo cl et passionnant je suis
horrible c'est vrai ah ben là j'ai pas
peur de le dire pour l'avertissement
c'est pas pour la photo parce que
pendant ma dernière chronique un moment
j'ai senti vous étiez plus du tout avec
moi et en rouvrir la séquence j'ai
compris pourquoi parce que quand je
parlais il vous est arrivé un drama way
regardait que c'est donc sans fous vous
avez vu jean claude van damme vous à
tous vents gilani devant cyril hanouna
dont 3 est inverse j'imagine que
personne n'a remarqué ce qui vous est
arrivé c'est le noble pendant que je
parlais regardez vous voulez
tranquillement vous tournez votre mais
ce que vous n'avez negri dont vous
pouvez maintenant
et quand vous revenez à l'image vous
apercevez que le bouton vous est resté
dans les mains regardez toute cette
détresse
30% j'ai dit ah oui mais voilà
l'acronyme est bien que plus c'est l'art
en colère et des regrets et pourtant ça
marche pas alors le désespoir mec que
mcgill a perdu samedi c'était un skate
je voudrais pas comme ça m'a pas dit à
l'antenne c'était la catastrophe
c'est la capacité que moi je me demande
je me dis qu'est ce qu'il fait et donc
j'ai regardé la maison et c'est
incroyable je suis vraiment choqué par
l'harmattan début s'il vous plaît au
régime hiro mobile il est perdu souriant
je souhaite et puis là c'est le drame
regardez le drame
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
une poignée cgc mieux te regarde après
quand tu fais de ta main non mais c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui ça va ça tiens ça a
l'air de tenir notre regard des jets
münchen à monter les chaînes ton dans
quelques importants la suite d'un film
d'horreur que tout le monde adore ça un
lacet pour du clown d'or s'est fait très
peur mais quelqu'un d'autre qui a fait
son grand retour cette semaine qui fait
encore plus peur elle a traumatisé des
millions de téléspectateurs
i la pire menace télévisuelle
marty elle a fait son grand retour
vous êtes le
[Applaudissements]
à bombay les parties à deux centrales
est de retour et fait des shows
incroyables crème avertissement quand
même pour cinq ans mais on a quand même
bien alors lundi vous avez ou verser la
saison de tp et avec lui une énorme
fiesta
franchement tout le budget passé là
dedans vous allez déguisé donc certains
chroniqueurs un casa des papes elle
entourée de danseurs on reconnaissait
presque personne un petit peu comme dans
danse avec les stars en fait vous allez
voir que les chroniqueurs autant bossé
la chorégraphie que quand il bosse
l'émission
[Musique]
la marina silva en piste sur les
danseurs et qui sont les crocs il mérite
il n'a pas le coeur en fête qui n'a pas
vu que les chroniqueurs n'avait rien
foutu cyril hanouna qui les félicite
pour leur prestation inoubliable
regarder merci à vous et vous avez
assumé la chorégraphie bravo on peut les
accueillir
j'ai mis tout ça la céleste côté claude
assurée à tour grave on peut les
accueillir fort
[Rires]
une rentrée en train de se [ __ ] de ma
tronche et c'est toujours comme ça non
mal et c'est pas fini vous allez voir
lorsqu'eric qu'est ce qui s'est passé le
31 août 2015 travaux d'un anneau 2015
par ma vie je crois qui est en jeu c'est
à ckoi je sais je sais j'ai revu
quelqu'un oui quelqu'un vous gagnez
beaucoup vous avez ramené ici
ouais c'est lui c'est matthieu delormeau
catégorie l'équipe touche pas à mon
poste
effectivement il se rappelle même plus
et 31 c'était un train de miliciens
louis simon et bien oui non et bienvenue
dans l'émission grecque va le voir les
audiences trois grâces et m'ont fait
direct décollement nrj 12 il reste
encore dix il reste encore des petites
c'est ça dont vous aviez besoin des
peuples un gars qui s'y connaissait et
en médias et ancien mais comme ici on
sait accueillir les nouveaux pour sa
première il s'était fait défoncer en
fait ça a duré toute sa première semaine
de suite les bars chine-ue
alors que ce que voulait rester avec
nous est ce qu on voulait vous mettre là
bas est écouté et revenir après un jeu
mari l'a fait partir parce qu'il va se
faire littéralement massacrées oui c'est
une sorte de sous l'habile à sa taille
était quelqu'un de sympa avec moi ça
fait sept ans qu'il me vend des
problèmes de merde j'avais un mauvais
débatteurs c'est à quelqu'un qui disait
bonjour facilement me retrouver avec lui
là franchement excusez moi mais ça me
gonfle et toute sa première semaine
machete prix d'attaqué sos ma famille a
besoin dès lors ça c'est toujours sur
nrj 12
casas et contrairement à vous mêmes les
téléspectateurs y aura mis plein la
gueule sinon est ce que vous voulez
éliminer quelqu'un tout de suite
éliminer matthieu delormeau
mais alors on dit souvent je suis
méchant avez-vous mathieu mais sans vous
on aurait jamais eu de séquences comme
celle ci qui parle de kit kat et du sexe
de cyril très gentiment vous avez un
petit plateau neymar sexe sur le plateau
est inquiet
sachant que je ne mens pas sourd après
16h et qu'ils étaient 17 ans
[Rires]
ces réponses
m
nous avons avec kigali